what is up reject nation john
what's his channel oh it's geom films
gom films
there's a link where in the description
box pin comment
there you go check his channel out today
we're gonna
do a reaction to chris evan reaction
captain america kills
let's do this
i just want gom films to notice us
episode 4 watch this with chris
i guess
man i miss the old gang i miss him a lot
[Music]
nice beat that should be a christmas
song
[Laughter]
hey that's the back of my head shouldn't
i be getting paid for this
well i guess later i'm going to be
calling feige i hate nazis
to the avengers hey those aren't friends
you're talking about the avengers not
the nazis
oh i'm glad you clarified that because i
was about to call you a racist
and also i know it looks good but please
don't eat the candy
no more keeping us in the dark look who
it is
it's like a good bad lip ready yeah
all that serum running through your
veins well what about all that spinach
in your vein mr papaya
drool came out of my mouth just now
congrats geo
bro god you broke them my love for this
episode has greatly increased
[Music]
losing his arm like that kind of reminds
me of that scene from star trek the next
generation
yeah this one oh oh they're taking his
arm off too
uh monkey's just like data in fact i'm
gonna call him beta
wow that works it works
oh oh wow where did that just come from
man popeye's gonna lose it
oh my god you gotta do this for every
episode of falcon winter solstice
i think he's confused
i hope you all had a good laugh if you
can please subscribe to geom films
and leave a comment below on what you
like i don't know if you guys can see
this i literally have
like little bits of tears coming out of
my eyes right now
yeah my sides hurt it's so
funny because people can i think
some people might get mad if they click
on the video thinking that oh this is
like a real one i feel like you should
just go with knowing it's not that
people do this kind of stuff all the
time but for what gom films does
the dubbing it's like yes does it sound
like kris sevens no the voice doesn't
sound like chris evans
we got an accent however the words that
he's choosing
and the the enunciation it's like a damn
good bad lip reading
and then what i love too is he edits it
like a reaction highlights clip for when
people do tv show reactions
on youtube and i was actually super
impressed with this one
because like the certain gestures that
chris evans will be doing the things
he'll be
like referencing or pointing to like the
clip that he got is just
it's so perfect and matches so well to
make it seem like he's talking about the
moment but then matching the dialogue
and then on top of that attitude of the
edit with the footage
of falcon winter soldier a lot of work
goes into this video a lot of
a lot of work goes into crafting this
so yeah it's easy to just kind of be
like oh he just slept it's not the just
the matthew mcconaughey interstellar one
that one famous
star wars force awakens just put a piece
of footage over it and let the original
scene do the rest
no this is a lot of a lot of
manipulation you got to do and i think
you did an
incredible job with it oh yeah well it's
charmingly low-fi
in a way that really sells it because
you know nowadays we're so used to
seeing
like celebrity joke videos that involve
deep faking or some kind of high-tech
gimmickry whereas this is literally like
i just imagined you doing the voiceovers
just like embodying the mannerisms so
that they would match like i feel like
that's the important thing and that's
how they match is you just really
got into embodying his physicality and
then using that to inform
the wackiness that you put like the
whole popeye bit like that is based kind
of on
this prolonged movement he does and it's
so freaking hilarious
and even though the voice doesn't sound
like chris evans the
the cadence and attitude that's coming
through with the voice
matches so well with matt with the
editors
i was going to call you racist i thought
he was good i think he's confused
you know what it's so funny it's some
funny ass [ __ ] is it here
yeah and it's not like obvious it's not
like trying to punch you with like a
chris evans joke every 10 seconds too
no it totally feels like he's just
watching this
and it had me thinking about that bucky
moment there's a couple things that have
me actually genuinely thinking about too
the bucky thing with data
i don't know how accurate that is i mean
it's wonderful he loses his arm a lot i
feel like
any time you got a metal arm people are
going to go for that anytime bucky is a
prominent character
in a movie or something he's going to
lose his arm at some point yeah i don't
know maybe it's more in reference to the
whole star wars how they
someone gets their hand chopped off
thing of how they include that in all
the marvel films
but it did also kind of have me thinking
okay there's rumors that captain america
it's all rumors i don't believe i
actually do not believe it
but if it comes true cool
i don't believe it but if it happens i'm
going to be excited that's
steve rogers chris evans it might appear
towards the
end of uh cap falcon winter soldier
regardless if he does or doesn't i'd be
so curious to know what his
what his feedback is on on this show you
know like this is essentially a captain
america part four
this whole series that they're doing and
so much of every every episode takes
time to remind you of steve rogers
of chris evans so i'd be i'd love to
know if hey if he saw it
and b like what he thinks of the like a
detailed
take on what he actually thinks of what
they've crafted together here
for uh falcon and winter soldier really
fascinating in fact if he
really should start a react review
series to the show
now that he's out of marvel for the
bigger parts of it now that he's not
doing yeah like the
main starring roles he should just react
to all their stuff and you know share
behind the scenes tidbits
and i feel like g.o.m films could should
do this for
like i would love to see this for the
rest of falcon and winter soldier man
oh dude yeah again it would give us that
that wish but in fantasy form it would
be perfect
because yeah gom films has edited once
for like the mark hamill one which one
really popular
he did do one a couple weeks ago that i
actually didn't check out the chris
evans reaction and new captain america
i i haven't seen that one yet but yeah
this guy's like a beast at this game
i think he's just so hilarious of what
he does now dub us
dub yeah just reacting all right guys
well subscribe
to geo and films you haven't done so
already subscribe to us keep a lookout
for our falcon and winter soldier
reaction coming
this week obviously i'm gonna do our
best to get it up
on friday again only two more episodes
left it's been a hell of a series
hell of a series i just want to see like
you know chris evans
was like actors on actors videos who's
that would holly report variety i forget
who one of them one of those right
um and i would love for him and wyatt
russell to do it though
how great would that be that'd be so
awesome
man these perspectives alone that would
get shared on just taking up that mantle
g
alright guys we'll catch you guys soon
see ya